you must have many questions so let's
begin with the most important one why
I'm here hey youtubers is Charlie and
Marvel just dropped a bombshell James
Spader is going to be Ultron and
Avengers 2 that's right it's crazy
so Marvel just announced that James
Spader is going to play the voice of
Ultron and Avengers age of Ultron we
don't know if it's going to be a
motion-capture role yet obviously Spader
is a fairly older gentleman so I'm
guessing that it will probably just be a
voice only role if you remember there
are a lot of rumors about how Jarvis
might be turning into Ultron in this
movie but if that's the case then that
means that they're dropping Paul Bettany
because he's actually been playing the
voice of Jarvis and all the Iron Man
movies so I feel kind of bad for him but
obviously this is a much bigger movie
they want a much bigger actor with a
much more recognizable voice so let me
know how you feel about the idea of
James Spader playing Ultron so obviously
Ultron has this really robotic voice so
it'll be interesting to see how they
change that obviously the voice of
Jarvis has been very British so I don't
think that James Spader is going to be a
British Ultron but I do think it's going
to be very interesting maîtres I should
really famous for playing really complex
really dark characters so I do think
that he brings a lot to the table he's
actually in this NBC show called the
blacklist and if you seen the trailers
for it it looks super dark so I'm
thinking that this is actually a really
good choice for Marvel if you remember
just Whedon showed the teaser for age of
Ultron at comic-con it basically just
showed this Iron Man helmet kind of
reconfiguring into the Ultron helmet so
I am guessing that Ultron will come from
Tony Stark and he won't come from Hank
Pym because they have announced that
Ultron will not appear in ant-man
and ant-man will not appear in Avengers
age of Ultron so I think there's really
interesting but I think for practical
reasons the audience is just really
familiar with the Jarvis character which
is much easier for Whedon to use that as
a tool to get to Ultron I actually kind
of thought that they were teasing this
in Iron Man 3 with all the outages and
the fact that Jarvis wouldn't talk back
to Tony whenever he was talking to it
but it'll be interesting to see how they
kind of evolved this AI into Ultron and
age of Ultron you've heard the comic
book series then you know that the movie
is actually going to have nothing to do
with the comic book series so I do think
this idea that Ironman is going to
create Ultron is much more plausible
well let me know what you think is Tony
Stark going to be responsible for the
creation of Jarvis it kind of seems like
that's the case and do you think
Ultron is going to be born from Jarvis
you should have seen me this morning
when I saw the news I was working on a
divergent preview and I just got done
taping when I looked at my phone and
said Marvel picks James Spader for
Ultron I basically dropped my phone I
was so surprised but this is really
exciting news let me know what you think
though are you excited to see James
Spader obviously you know people like
Vin Diesel will be voicing Groot and
he'll be doing motion capture but he's
an action star so that's a little bit
different and Bradley Cooper will
probably be doing Rocket Raccoon so it's
just a little bit different though just
because James Spader isn't really known
for doing action roles and obviously
this Ultron character is much more of a
mastermind so I think that's going to
lend itself a little bit more to
Spader's physique I'll be doing a lot
more Marvel videos this fall be sure to
subscribe to get them all I got a ton of
awesome stuff coming remember Winter
Soldier is coming next year guardians of
the galaxy
we have Thor 2 coming up in November
that'll be really exciting in the
meantime you can click here to see that
age of Ultron video I did the other day
and you can click here to watch the new
video I did this morning I just started
a new vlog so let me know what you think
of that - high fives thanks for watching
good luck - James Spader
you